.
>> Hannity: ALSO TONIGHT, THE
SAUDI ARABIAN MINISTRY OF
FOREIGN AFFAIRS ISSUED A LENGTHY
STATEMENT IN RESPONSE TO BIDEN
SAYING HE WOULD AGREE SS THE
U.S. RELATIONSHIP TO THE
KINGDOM.
THE SAUDIS HAD SOME THOUGHTS ON
JOE BIDEN.
THEY ACCUSED HIM OF LYING ABOUT
THEIR MOTIVATIONS FOR THE
PRODUCTION CUT AND THEN THEY SAY
THAT HE WANTED THE SAUDIS AND
OPEC AND ALSO THAT NOW INCLUDES
RUSSIA TO DELAY THEIR
ANNOUNCEMENT AND THERE CAR BY
ONE MONTH.
THEY WROTE, POSTPONING THE OPEC
PLUS DECISION FOR A MONTH
ACCORDING TO WHAT IS BEEN
SUGGESTED WOULD'VE HAD A STOMACH
NEGATIVE ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES.
NEXT THEY PUT BIDEN ON NOTICE
THAT THEY WON'T LISTEN TO ANY OF
HIS DICTATES TO DISTORT THEIR
WORK AND SETTING THE OIL PRICES.
IF THAT'S NOT HUMILIATING AND
BAD ENOUGH, THE SAUDIS HAD SOME
PARTING WORDS FOR BIDEN.
THE KINGDOM OF HERS THAT INFUSE
ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH THE U.S.
AS A STRATEGIC ONE THAT SERVES
THE COMMON DRESS OF BOTH
COUNTRIES.
WOW.
HERE KNOW WHAT THAT DOMINANT
REACTION, FLORIDA SENATOR MARCO
RUBIO, HE'S ON THE FOREIGN
SERVICES COMMITTEE.
MY INTERPRETATION IS THAT
JOE BIDEN WAS TOLD IN NO
UNCERTAIN TERMS NOT ONLY WILL
THEY NOT INCREASE THE PRODUCTION
OF OIL BUT THEY'RE GONNA CUT
THEIR PRODUCTION OF OIL.
IN JOE'S ANSWER WAS, CAN YOU
JUST DELAY THE ANNOUNCEMENT A
MONTH AND THAT LEADS ME TO
CONCLUDE THE STRONG POSSIBILITY
THAT JOE BIDEN WAS TRYING TO
COLLUDE WITH THE SAUDIS, OPEC
PLUS, RUSSIA, AND OPEC NATIONS
FROM PRESENTING THIS INFORMATION
FROM BECOMING PUBLIC BEFORE THE
MIDTERM ELECTION.
IS THAT A CONSPIRACY THEORY OR
IS IT ACCURATE?
>> THE PIECES BEGIN TO FIT.
THEY ALREADY PLAY POLITICS WITH
OIL.
HE THREATENED SHE'S GOING TO
EVERYBODY OUT OF BUSINESS, THE
REFINING CAPACITY IS LESS THAN
ONE DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT.
THEN YOU HAVE THEM START DIPPING
INTO THE STRATEGIC RESERVES.
WE HAVE THEM OUT AFTER THE OPEC
EMBARGO OF THE 70s BECAUSE WE
NEVER WANTED TO BE IN THAT SPOT
AGAIN.
THAT'S FOR HURRICANES AND WERE
NOT THERE FOR MIDTERMS.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS USING IT FOR
HER.
THEN WE GET INTO THAT SITUATION
NOW OR AT ARE ASKING THEIR OWN
BEST INTERESTS.
THEY WANT TO SET OIL PRICES IN A
WAY THAT'S GOOD FOR THEM AND AT
THE SAME TIME IT'S OPEC PLUS
RUSSIA BUT THE DOING IT TO
PUBLISH AMERICA ON JOE BIDEN.
WE SHOULD BE IN THIS POSITION
REDWARE AND OIL PRODUCING
COUNTRY IF WE WANT TO BE.
THE REASON WE ARE NOT IS BECAUSE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WILL
NOW ALLOW IT TO BE PRODUCED ON
THE RADICAL LEFT ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS TOLD THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY, OIL AND
OTHERS, WERE GONNA PUT YOU OUT
OF BUSINESS.
AND WE FIND OURSELVES IN A
POSITION AS BEGGARS, THE MOST
POWERFUL COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
HAS TO BEG THESE THIRD-RATE
COUNTRIES.
>> Hannity: SO HE'S BEGGING
THESE COUNTRIES THAT HATE OUR
GUTS.
WE HAVE MORE NATURAL RESOURCES
AS YOU KNOW THAN ALL THESE
COUNTRIES COMBINED.
WE CAN BE ENERGY INDEPENDENT FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR ME.
JOE BIDEN FOR SOME REASON THINKS
IT'S OKAY THAT WE IMPORT OIL BUT
WE CAN'T PRODUCE IT DOMESTICALLY
BECAUSE OF MOTHER EARTH.
THE SAUDIS DIDN'T LIKE JOE'S
COMMENTS ABOUT REASSESSING THE
RELATIONSHIP AFTER THEY CUT
PRODUCTION OF OIL.
MY QUESTION IS, WHAT A JOE BIDEN
THEN ASKED THEM TO DELAY THEIR
DECISION, DELAY THEIR
ANNOUNCEMENT, HE KNEW THEY WERE
GOING TO COOPERATE, INFECT THERE
AND CUT PRODUCTION WHAT HE
WANTED DELAYED UNTIL AFTER THE
MIDTERMS?
TO ME THE ANSWER IS OBVIOUS.
I THINK WE NEED A CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION.
YOU'D BE A PERFECT CANDIDATE
FOR.
WAS HE TRYING TO COLLUDE WITH
FOREIGN COUNTRIES TO GET
INFLUENCE IN THE UPCOMING
MIDTERM ELECTIONS?
>> I THINK THERE IS NO DOUBT
TIMING TELLS YOU, IT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION.
DON'T DO IT UNTIL AFTER NOVEMBEE
WANTS IS WHAT HAPPENED ALREADY,
OVER THE WEEKEND, A SPIKE IN
OIL.
A COUPLE WEEKS LATER IT GETS
PRICED AND AT THE PUMP, WHEN
AMERICANS ARE GOING GO VOTE.
THEY'VE BEEN GOING AROUND FOR
WEEKS BRAGGING ABOUT HOW GAS
PRICES WERE COMING DOWN.
HE WAS TAKING CREDIT FOR THAT.
NOISE CAN HAVE TO TAKE THE BLAME
AND HE DESERVES IT.
I BELIEVE THEY'RE MESSING AROUND
WITH IT FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
BUT ALSO THINK IT'S INDICATIVE
OF HOW THESE RADICAL LEFT
MARXIST MISFITS HAVE PUT US IN
THE POSITION WERE IN NOW AS A
COUNTRY.
THEY'RE OKAY WITH GETTING OIL
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES BUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO PRODUCE IT HERE
AND THAT LEAVES US VULNERABLE,
NATURAL GAS AND ALL THE
BYPRODUCTS COME FROM THAT, YOU
NAME IT.
>> Hannity: IT'S REALLY A
SHAME SENATOR.
YOU LOOK AT THE SUFFERING OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, EVERY TIME THEY
FILL UP THEIR GAS TANK, THESE
ARE SCARY TIMES.
ALL OF IT IS PREVENTABLE.
SENATOR RUBIO, YOUR RACE IN
FLORIDA IS CRITICAL IF
REPUBLICANS ARE TO HAVE ANY
CHANCE OF HOLDINGS GETTING A
MAJORITY.
WERE FOLLOWING YOUR ELECTION
CLOSELY, WE KNOW YOU'RE UP BUT
WE LIKE TO SEE WOULD BUY DOUBLE
JUDGES IF POSSIBLE.
>> I N